[Musik]
das ist die berliner luft luft luft de
aus dem auspuff deutschland stinkt die
luft in den großstädten macht krank und
da muss ich von der autolobby auch mal
ganz selbstkritisch sagen ich scheiß
drauf
es geht hier um arbeitsplätze freunde da
muss man als deutscher auch mal opfer
bringen also ich zu dir autofan die
natürlichste art der fortbewegung schöne
in aschen ledersessel parken mm dicken
diesel durch die stadt brezeln die
schummel software stattet die
abgasreinigung aus damit der motor so
richtig durchatmen kann so moment damals
fenster zur seele luft da draußen
wir sehen das ja ein stück weit auch als
service ja viele stuttgarter zb würden
ja totale panik schieben wenn sie ihre
stadt mal ohne smog sehen würde nach dem
shake sie ich lebe ja in stuttgart
ich weiss mal eben den verkehrsminister
am büros so an die tu was für dein geld
ich brauche heute seinen dienstwagen
klar oder
die kanzlerin hat sich selbst nach dem
vw skandal noch persönlich dafür
eingesetzt dass der stickoxidausstoß auf
der straße mehr als doppelt so hoch
liegen darf wie im labor und jetzt
kommen die kommunen hier mit
fahrverboten und ermittlungen
neulich haben sie den audi-chef in
u-haft gesteckt hallo würden sie von
diesem mann keinen gebrauchten euro für
diesel kaufen immer mehr politiker
wenden sich gegen die autoindustrie
reden sogar schon vom verbraucherschutz
verbraucherschutz
das heißt dass die industrie vom
verbraucher geschützt wird
ich bin so so häufig die
staatsanwaltschaft braunschweig hat
allen ernstes ein bußgeld gegen vw
verhängt zum glück nur eine milliarde
euro eine milliarde dass es ungefähr
sorgt wenn ich ein penner hier ein hunde
geben würde
hier mein freund kommt jetzt aber
wirklich mache ich natürlich nicht sorry
alter ist einfach keine lobby konnten
jetzt aber wirklich fahrverbote das
bringt doch gar nix autos raus aus den
städten warum ist die fußgänger die sind
doch das problem ja ich meine ich der
feine haben saubere luft atmen ruhig was
kommt als nächstes
gesundes essen im supermarkt oder was
rate mal wer fällt mir ein witz ein
[Musik]
ich habe noch ein treffen sich zwei vw
diesel aus hamburg sogar eine domain
besitzer hatte ihn umgebracht ich
erfreut war sagt der andere habe die
abgase mit einem schlauch in den
innenraum geleitet nähe des heutigen
staates gewarnt stimmung
wir sorgen auch dafür dass eure schönen
diese nicht durch hardware umrüstungen
verhunzt werden die industrie könnte
nämlich nachträglich harnstoff
katalysatoren einbauen aber das würde
geld kosten also hör auf zu heulen doch
bitte hans katalysatoren selber aktiv
werden
mein gott habe ich euch in der harnstoff
kommt weiter fahren und nichts zu danken
ich mein nicht zu tanken
ich meine elektroautos haben einfach
keinen geilen sound
die machen keinen spaß ehrlich nichts
passiert
wie gesagt elektroautos sind viel
gefährlicher als diesel
stickoxid
[Gelächter]